Connie Britton opens up about Nashville  getting cancelled surprised fans of the  beloved a musical drama were stunned  last week after it was confirmed the  show won't be returning for a fifth  season I'm so bad there's gonna be some  kind of Hail Mary pass here you know but  I don't I don't either  me too was with Connie Britton on  Saturday at the GLAAD of Media Awards in  New York City where she candidly  revealed her initial reaction after  hearing the news I was not necessarily  surprised the actress also opened up  about her co-star hayden Panettiere who  revealed on twitter last week she's  taking time off to focus on her health  amid her battle with postpartum  depression connie said she hasn't spoken  to Hayden since they wrapped but assured  us she's doing well she's gonna be great  she's doing